on termine avec un point sur l'économie
les bourses mondiales sur sont sur un
petit nuage
elle voit deux elle vole de record en
record notamment un pari avec un 4 40 à
plus de 7000 points du jamais vu depuis
la bulle internet plus haut historique
aussi à wall street et au dessus des
indices boursiers sur le bitcoin alors
tout va t'il si bien sûr la planète
finance comment expliquer une telle
euphorie des bourses ne sont elles pas
déconnectée de l'économie réelle on en
parle tout de suite avec un l'économiste
jacques sapir dans l'édito rico
bonsoir à jacques alors l'euphorie
actuelle des bourses n'est-elle pas mal
scène alors que l'inflation monte que
les banques centrales se prépare à être
moins généreuse un oui on peut dire
effectivement qu'il y à un élément
malsain dans cette espèce d'envolée des
bourses on voit d'ailleurs que
l'inflation est aussi en train de monter
et généralement c'est deux choses qui ne
font pas spécialement bon ménage alors
oui vous avez raison les bourses se
prépare dans les différents pays a
adopté des programmes de réduction de
leurs achats voire de hausse des taux
d'intérêt mais au delà on peut se
demander si justement ces bourses sont
pas devenus elle-même les prisonnières
des marchés financiers qu'elles sont
censées justement surveiller chaque est
ce que les bourses sont sont elles
réellement le forez qu'un à oui alors la
samantha tout à fait alors prenons le
cas d'abord du cac 40 de la bourse de
paris
il vient de passer à la fin de la
semaine dernière un record historique
les 7000 points qui n'avaient pas
atteint d'ailleurs à son plus haut en
2000 au moment de la bulle internet et
il continue encore aujourd'hui à être
au-dessus des 7000 points même chose
pour le dow jones à wall street à new
york le dow jones est au dessus de 36000
oui il est évident que actuellement nous
avons des plus hauts historiques pour
les bourses alors justement comment
l'expliquer à quoi c'est dû alors il ya
une explication d'ordre réel il faut le
savoir parce que bien sûr avec la crise
de l'aco vide certaines entreprises ont
tiré leur épingle du jeu les gaffes à un
google
amazon etc ont fait de très gros profits
ont vu leurs dividendes augmenter et
donc il est normal que leur valorisation
mais maintenant il faut quand même dire
que le reste de la côte a quand même
connu une une année et demie nettement
plus compliquée que ce qui s'est passé
pour ces entreprises à et donc on voit
bien que ce ne sont pas simplement les
éléments réels qui propulse les bourses
à ses sommets en réalité il y à bien la
politique des banques centrales les
banques centrales qui ont baissé très
fortement les taux d'intérêt qui
n'arrêtent pas d'injecter de l'argent
dans l'économie et ça évidemment ça
provoque l'équivalent d'une bulle
boursière et dans quelles proportions
alors ça c'est des proportions qui sont
assez considérables si on prend par
exemple le bilan de la banque centrale
européenne et il a augmenté de 24 % en
un an si vous voulez de de fin 2010 9 à
fin 2020 on a 24 % d'augmentation du
bilan si on prend maintenant les actifs
de ce qu'on appelle l'eurosystème c'est
à dire le réseau des banques centrales
de tous les pays et qui font partie de
la zone euro là c'est encore plus
spectaculaire et le ces actifs étaient
de l'ordre de 2600 milliards d'euros en
2019 ils sont en fin 2020 à
3500 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 40 % et si maintenant
on sort d'europe et qu'on regarde aux
états unis c'est encore plus fou si vous
voulez le bilan de la réserve fédérale
est pas fait de 4200 1 milliards à plus
de 7000 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 72% en moins de sept
mois donc oui il y a bien eu des
injections massives
du point de vue monétaire dans ces
injections justement massive de monnaie
dans l'économie est ce que c'est
soutenable alors c'est bien justement la
raison qu'on se pose et même chose par
exemple pour les taux d'intérêt alors
aujourd'hui on a déjà plusieurs banques
centrales qui ont annoncé leur volonté
de réduire leur politique de rachat des
titres de commencer à faire remonter les
taux d'intérêt nous avons la banque du
canada la banque centrale du canada ça
c'était à la fin du mois d'octobre
début novembre
c'est la réserve fédérale elle même qui
a annoncé qu'il y aurait probablement de
hausse de taux dans l'année 2022 et qui
a annoncé un resserrement de ses rachats
d'actions la banque d'angleterre
elle-même a fait des annonces dans ce
sens et puis il ya déjà des banques qui
ont sauté le pas 1 il faut quand même le
dire en particulier
la banque de corée bon bref il y a
globalement aujourd'hui une forme de
tendance générale à la restriction
monétaire plus ou moins accéléré suivant
les zones et en europe 1 alors lequel
l'europe justement est intéressant parce
que on voit bien que l'europe étant un
petit peu en retard par rapport aux
états unis pour la reprise madame
christine lagarde lors de la dernière
réunion qui a eu lieu à la bce a
maintenu le discours en disant non il
est trop tôt pour parler d'un
resserrement et elle a dit que
fondamentalement les taux ne bougerait
pas tant que l'inflation de manière
durable ne dépasserait pas l'objectif et
je rappelle que cet objectif est de 2%
sauf que sauf que l'inflation est déjà à
4,6 pour cent en allemagne à 3 % en
moyenne dans la zone euro donc ils sont
au dessus comme l'allemagne et donc on
voit bien qu'il va y avoir des pressions
d'ores et déjà la semaine dernière et au
début de cette semaine la presse
allemande a très violemment attaqué
madame lagarde l'appelant madame
inflation d'ailleurs l'attaquant de
manière pas très élégante il faut le
dire et donc on voit bien que la banque
centrale européenne ne pourra pas
maintenir sa politique elle sera obligée
et probablement ça sera annoncé lors de
la prochaine réunion qui doit avoir lieu
au début du mois de décembre elle va
être obligée d'annoncer beaucoup plus
vite des formes de restriction de sa
politique d'achats elle doit en
particulier décidé de la poursuite du
programme ppp le programme de rachat qui
était consécutif à la crise endémique
normalement ce programme devait se
terminer au mois de mars 2022 il n'est
pas impossible qu'il se termine plus
vite que prévu et de ce point de vue là
on doit avoir vraiment les yeux rivés
sur l'inflation en allemagne alors est
ce que vous pensez jacques les banques
centrales pourraient bientôt changer de
stratégie oui je pense que samantha que
c'est absolument inévitable un an pour
pour plusieurs raisons nous avons tout
d'abord cette inflation qui est peut
être transitoire mais combien d'années
mettons sous le mot transitoire il est
clair qu'elle se poursuivra en 2022 nous
avons les bulles d'actifs nous avons un
l'immobilier qui montent beaucoup nous
avons le bit coin qui monte lui aussi
beaucoup avec l'ensemble des autres
crypto monnaie et il y a un problème
aussi d'inégalités sociales parce qu'on
sait très bien que les personnes qui
possèdent des titres boursiers c'est
grosso modo le 1 pour cent le plus riche
au mieux le d pour cent le plus riche de
la population donc ce sont eux qui
bénéficient d'une certaine manière de
co2 tout le reste de la population n'en
bénéficient pas et par contre subi
l'inflation et puis il ya un troisième
point on voit aujourd'hui et ça a été
très clair par exemple dans l'allocution
café emmanuel macron le 9 novembre on
voit qu'on est en train de s'orienter
vers une politique
d'investissement extrêmement important
et d'une certaine manière cette
politique et dia elle va nécessiter des
engagements de l'état de plus en plus
important là encore il faut entendre ce
qu a dit emmanuel macron le marché ne
peut pas tout l'état va devoir
intervenir et donc les banques centrales
vont devoir s'adapter à cette nouvelle
situation est à ce point de vue là
élaboré une nouvelle stratégie mais le
faire sans casser la croissance actuelle
et c'est peut-être ça le principal défi
qu'elles ont devant l'antenne merci
vocaux avoue jacques sapir pour cette
année merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine merci